[Music]
guerilla games hotly-anticipated ps4
exclusive horizon zero dawn is just
around the corner so it's time to
outline ten things you should know about
the third-person open-world action RPG
that is horizon zero dawn the game is
set 1,000 years in the future after
robot dinosaurs growing strength in
numbers and are ultimately taking over
the world
meaning humans are no longer at the top
of the food cheese land you are on a
quest to find out what happened to
humanity and why they abandoned the
planet this will be set against the
backdrop of a villainous tribe
resurrecting and corrupting mechanical
beasts from years gone by as you'd
expect
horizon zero dawn is completely open
world which you are free to explore
snowy mountains deserts and jungles make
up the majority of locations but expects
a huge variety of environments which are
home to different enemy types and tribes
the day/night cycle is here as expected
and will impact enemy encounters this is
an action RPG title with ties to Elder
Scrolls assassin's creed and even the
division all rolled into one perfect
little package perks leveling up XP it's
all here so expect to be playing this
game for a very long time to get the
most out of it
basically everything you want from an
RPG campaign in 2017 looks to be here
you will have access to a huge arsenal
over the course of the game from basic
weapons and traps to highly customisable
weaponry with multiple ammo options or
modification slots we've been told
battles will be in three types or a
mixture of all three prepare engage and
escape Oh have you seen the tripwire
weapon this bad boy will make you feel
like Luke Skywalker taking down an at-at
so satisfying so satisfying the speaking
of enemy types there's a smorgasbord to
get your teeth into if like me you've
been keeping an eye on horizon zero dawn
footage you will know there seems to be
uncountable enemy types from futuristic
Brachiosaurus to winged enemies that
resemble pterodactyls different enemies
mean different tactics explained and
different loot drops once again feeding
into the action RPG genre long-lost
tribes are scattered throughout the game
for you to discover some tribes are
quite easy to find and reward you with
outfits and armor but hidden tribes are
what you need to aim for they have
unique armor sets which have far better
stats so maybe don't take the beaten
path and instead go on an adventure
we've seen a horse
mechanics that will prove game defining
as I've already mentioned tripping up
techno dinosaurs is my personal
highlight but there's also of scanning
enemies to find weaknesses slowing down
time shooting panels and armor off
boards and even hacking a Dinobot to
fight alongside you so many
possibilities in horizon zero dawn fancy
taking horizon online well tough look
this is completely single play again
with no ties to multiplayer this will
hopefully give us a longer and more
satisfying campaign single players of
the world rejoice horizon zero dawn will
have no loading screens no tutorials and
is only available on ps4 and ps4 pro
horizon zero dawn is coming to you on
March 1st if you're in the UK and
February 28th if you're in North America
for all the territories keep checking
back as the date has moved a few times
in recent months so are you buying
horizon zero dawn have you pre-ordered
are you waiting for the reviews please
let us know below or and please
subscribe and help our little channel
grow
I'd really appreciate that I'm Adam from
Playstation grenade I'll see you next
time
[Music]